James Earl Jones is the only actor who  has actually broken me apart has  deconstructed me to the place where I  was a sobbing stammering mess his  performance on Broadway in fences was  the essence of what truly great acting  is i sat there mesmerised as he set the  molecules spinning between him and the  audience willing each one of us to  redefine what it means to be a human  being the fragility complexity  imperfection violence but also most  importantly the capacity for  transcendence and redemption when I went  backstage to kneel at his feet I on it I  just I couldn't stop crying James was  very sweet and he gave me time to kind  of semi collect myself so tonight I just  want to say to him thank you for what he  has given me and all those who have been  touched by his supreme artistry on stage  on television and in all those wonderful  films he has rearranged us for the  better  forever James Earl Jones is indeed a  world treasure  you